bienvenue
crois moi une fille aussi canon est
aussi pété de thunes existe pas en fait
il vient de passer deux ans constamment
plongée dans ses livres excusez moi
jean marc tu veulent sa voiture non
j'emprunte
allez montre que fais-tu tous les jours
jusqu'à la tua les projets comment vois
tu ton avenir au mène une vie simple
avec une fille qui m'attend à la maison
tu nous as fait un pauvre ou dîner
causerie irani de skoda yoü and i have
hockey
ils ont une
j'adore j'adore ça
avant ils ne se seraient jamais
comporter de cette façon jamais ressenti
ça pour personnes âgées peux-tu me rend
fou
cela n'a jamais inquiété qu'ils ne
vivent pas l'avis de tous les jeunes de
son âge
j'espère me tromper mais j'ai le
sentiment qu'il ya certaines choses que
tu le caches monde
c'était il ya longtemps ils ont appelé
les flics et dis-moi dressé
tu aller fouiller dans son passé
la ville n'est pas un criminel tu aurais
dû me le dire je t'avais prévenu
j'epère faux pas